we're continuing our coverage of some of
the most important and consequential
races in 2022 one such race is the
Georgia Senate election this is the race
in which Democrat Rafael Warnock is the
incumbent and on the other side very
disturbingly Herschel Walker former NFL
football player is the Republican
nominee there is a new series of videos
of Herschel Walker at some kind of event
and in this event you know we've heard
Herschel Walker be completely incoherent
about the economy
we've heard Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about uh gun
violence we've heard Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about social media
here he delves into issues of race
relations and the Constitution and what
he refers to as the 14th Amendment now
that is that's not my pronunciation I
want to be very clear but this is
another one of these examples where
Walker looks visibly confused by the
things coming out of his mouth he
doesn't seem to know what he's saying
and certainly no one in the room has any
clue what this guy is saying and he is
even
even in the polls with Raphael Warnock
this is one of the most important races
not only is it important
because if Democrats do hold the Senate
it may be by only one seat and if this
race doesn't go the way of Raphael
Warnock it could be because of Herschel
Walker that Democrats lose control of
the Senate it's important for that
reason it's also important because this
guy is so unqualified to be a senator
that
it really puts in serious relief I guess
I would say you really feel the texture
of how absurd the modern Republican
party has become that they're willing to
vote for a guy like this so let's listen
to this first clip about the 14th
Amendment
whoa
I said probably read the Bible
forgiveness and I said if you read the
Constitution and the 14th Amendment do
you know our forefather was apologizing
for the whiteness because they said
every man be treated Fair
but what has happened we elected the
wrong people to office that didn't pick
up a ton up and run with it okay dude
do you know what he just said
if you read the Constitution
the 14th Amendment
you know our forefather was apologizing
for their whiteness because they say
every man be treated Fair
but what has happened we elected the
wrong people to office that didn't pick
up the Baton and run with it
I don't know what that means
about what was happening whether they're
trying to fix it yeah
and the woman to his left nodding she
seems to get it I don't know what he's
talking about guys I genuinely don't and
these are just the top scrambled is the
only way I can describe the talking
points
um here's another example of this stuff
and you know what what is true is what
has been pointed out by some of our
viewers he's doing like a red meat word
salad it's like a it's like a republican
red meat Bingo where even if it's
completely scrambled in terms of its
syntax
um there are individual words there that
are triggers to Republicans to get mad
we laugh but they're talking about a
green agenda they get mad at me because
I said I don't want any more trees I
don't I want police officers right so
this is like mixing two things green
agenda oh that's very bad very very bad
and I want police officers oh yeah yeah
we support the police I mean okay
not the law enforcement officers that
handled the search warrant at Trump's
house and not the Capitol Police that
were there on January 6th we don't
support them but as a general concept we
support police officers
[Applause]
87 RS agents
87
RS agents now it's just a scrambled
talking point you guys might remember
there's this talking point about Joe
Biden's hiring 87 000 new IRS agents now
the truth is 55 000 of them are over the
next period of time because there's so
many employees retiring from the IRS
it's just to replace them we'll go over
the details of those numbers Friday but
the talking point is 87 000 IRS agents
the talking point is a lie
and Herschel Walker calls the talking
point 87 agents
trees no
you know what I can tell you this I
happen to be doing the Judah was telling
you about the theme weeks I was doing
he's doing a theme week I don't know if
it's infrastructure or whatever and so
what's the scariest thing about all of
this
the scariest thing about all of this is
that if you look at the real clear
politics average Georgia Senate Walker
versus Warnock you see that it is now a
tie
if you look at the last four polls it's
Walker plus one in the right-leaning
Trafalgar pole Walker plus two in an
Emerson pole Walker plus three in an
Insider Advantage poll and Warnock plus
six in a Quinnipiac pull now I will tell
you I believe the Quinnipiac poll is
probably the highest quality poll of the
four that's the one that has Warnock
winning
but this is really scary stuff the
people of Georgia May send a man who
can't explain his views on any issue to
be one of 100 members of the Senate if
you're listening today and you'd like to
take a look at those clips I just played
head on over to our Instagram at
davidpackman show and you can check out
the full horror of those clips